why should fans experience Indiana Jones
and the dial of Destiny and iMac well
we're just working hand in hand with
with the IMAX technicians as we hand off
our imagery our you know we do we we
have to do a separate pass on the images
um to work with your laser projectors
and we also retool our mix for your
particular Matrix of sound and the way
the speakers are distributed it is
absolutely tailored for the theaters
that you guys build so when you're
making an Indiana Jones film you are
working to make a movie that is
cinematically inventive that produces
beautiful images for the audience to
behold on a big screen and also in a
shared experience with others that
you're enjoying this adventure these
Vistas these other countries this
globetrotting on a giant screen